southern nevada shining purple today as
you can tell for domestic violence
awareness month it's just really a
strong reminder as cases are on the rise
christian caceres has a story of one
woman who went from being a victim to an
advocate
he beat me up with close fists on my
left
i remember i counted to five after five
i couldn't count anymore
i felt like i was going to die
helpless and alone is how aurelia soto
recalls her time with her ex-husband
after years of violence a man she says
promised her a bright future after she
arrived from mexico but was quickly
isolated and controlled i ended up in
the hospital that's when i said no more
because he wanted to kill me cases like
sotos are on the rise in southern nevada
according to safe house they say nevada
is known to be one of the states with
the highest rates among adults and
children
they say one in four women are or will
be a victim of domestic violence the
ways that that can be done maybe through
controlling their finances
isolation is a very large technique this
is definitely
very prominent in the immigrant
community marsy's law which protects
victims through the judicial process is
urging nevadans and iconic venues to go
purple in support
soto is taking it one step further as
she is part of the numerous local
organizations offering a helping hand i
never forget
it
when they say it takes one person
christian casa is live local now
if you or someone you know needs help
you can call the national domestic
violence hotline that number is right
there on your screen remember it is
confidential and it's available 24 7.